as we get the upper hand on the cobit 19
virus doctors worldwide can now
concentrate
on the long-term side effects so so far
we've told you about brain fog
fatigue hair loss and a whole segment of
people with multiple symptoms that just
don't go away
so in this special health watch report
there's growing concern about a
lingering and
annoying impact on your hearing
i never had a fever i never had a cough
i never lost my sense of taste and smell
sherry petta's coveted symptoms were
fairly mild
but within days there was one severe
symptom
my whole body is buzzing i'm buzzing i
feel like
i'm electric my ears are ringing and my
whole body is buzzing a certified
child life specialist peta works at a
hospital
so when her ears started ringing her
brain and her gut
told her it was cobit related what's
going to happen to me
how bad is this going to get it's this
new onset
you know bothersome high-pitched
ringing sensation dr michael kubala is
an ear nose and throat surgeon in north
texas
he's seen plenty of patients with
tinnitus related to covet
some are just mild symptoms but some are
you know even
severe enough to produce anxiety
depression you know sleep deprivation in
march
the ringing got so paralyzing for kent
taylor
he died by suicide after experiencing
unbearable
postcovid 19 symptoms taylor was the ceo
of the popular restaurant chain
texas roadhouse his struggle made
national headlines the studies show
anywhere between
five and fifteen percent of patients
have the tinnitus
after their infection and anywhere
between about
three and eight percent may have
permanent or sudden hearing loss
so even though there may be a small
amount of sufferers nationwide
the impact on their lives is huge but
this
electricity this ringing of the ear
that that started in october and now
it's may
i think i got really teared up the first
time somebody told me get used to it
because i was like i cannot imagine just
trying to get used to this this is crazy
it's in my head all the time
there's no you know magic treatment to
get rid of it
it never seems to go away so doctors
suggest
masking techniques like white noise
meditation
even counseling something called
cognitive behavioral therapy which is
essentially like
psychology counseling to help
essentially retrain the brain on how to
respond to these
to these noises for this active wife and
mother of two
tinnitus is part of her new normal
sometimes it's very loud
sometimes it's quiet and i really don't
notice it i believe
it's always there to some degree
so if you or maybe someone you know is
suffering with ringing or hearing loss
doctors urge you to get a hearing test
now studies are underway really across
the world now on how the virus impacts
your hearing
but at this point there's really no
definitive way to treat it and quiet
that buzzing in your head